today's video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building a beautiful website and growing
your online presence more details on
them later in today's video Jerry
Seinfeld called Richard Pryor the
Picasso of our profession both Comedy
Central and Rolling Stone magazine
ranked him as the greatest General comic
of all time he was first person ever to
be awarded the Mark Twain Prize for
American humor and if we were to mention
all of the accolades and accomplishments
that he had ever received we'd be here
all day all you need to know is that
when it comes to Comedy Richard Pryor
was a man when it came to everything
else though it was just explored and as
weak as everybody else from a deeply
atypical sometimes traumatizing
childhood to an adulthood dominated by
vices in addiction today we're going to
be taking a candid look at the life of
one of the funniest people to ever pick
up a microphone
[Music]
Richard Franklin Lennox Thomas Pryor was
born on December 1 1940 at Saint Francis
Hospital in Peoria Illinois the son of
Leroy Buck Pryor and Gertrude Thomas to
say that Richard Pryor didn't get to
live a fun happy and carefree childhood
would be the understatement of the
century for starters he was part of
black family in the mid-20th century in
Illinois that alone was enough to make
life the complete opposite of fun happy
and carefree black people had a curfew
only a handful of businesses in town
would serve them and half of the black
population was unemployed while the
other half could only find menial jobs
like working in a slaughterhouse or
driving trucks then of course there was
a looming threat of violence and
lynchings that represented a ubiquitous
threat in their lives Richard Pryor grew
up in a brothel owned an operator by his
grandmother Marie Carter Pryor where his
mother worked as a prostitute and his
father as a pimp slash enforcer his
grandmother whom Richard simply called
Mama was the one who looked after him
most of the time and was the primary
influence in its early life that being
said Pryor made it clear that Marie
Carter was a tough no-nonsense woman a
Survivor who endured more than a fair
share of hardships in her own life and
tough love was the only kind of love you
were getting with her prior described
his grandmother as a large sunflower big
strong bright appealing but was also her
mean tough controlling from a young age
Richard was exposed to the harsh
realities of life in a very graphic and
uncensored way his grandma made him wise
to all the injustices and prejudices he
would endure due to the color of his
skin while his parents never really hid
the fact that they never wanted him but
it could have been a lot worse prior
later repined when he was a kid he once
found a dead baby in a shoebox so at
least it was content that that wasn't
his fate that's just one grisly example
of the things that young Richard
witnessed firsthand that would have
traumatized most other people when
Richard was born his parents were not
married they did get married a few years
later in 1943 after his father got
drafted by the Army but it wasn't
exactly what you'd call a fairy tale
marriage buckfryer was not made for
military life and he was sent home after
just seven months with a Section 8
discharge back in Peoria his
relationship with his new wife was
tempestuous often violent and in 1946
Gertrude Thomas took five-year-old
Richard and left a husband going to live
with her parents in Springfield Illinois
she filed for divorce that same year
citing extreme and repeated cruelty but
the judge sided with the father since
Gertrude had a history of running away
and granted Buck prior full custody of
Richard thus sending him back to the
brothel in Peoria since real life didn't
offer up too many rays of sunshine and
rainbows unsurprisingly young Richard
sought comfort in the world of fantasy
he would sneak into Cinemas in town and
pretend he was the heroes that he saw on
screen prow was inspired by men like
Kirk Douglas John Wayne and Boris Karlov
although oddly enough his favorite
cinematic hero was a Western actor named
Lash LaRue who always wore black from
head to toe and used a whip instead of a
pistol then during the early 50s Richard
started gravitating towards comedy after
he saw his first Jerry Lewis movie
around the same time he was forced to
leave the neighborhood that he grew up
in after it was torn down to build a
bridge this meant living someplace else
and going to a new school the
predominantly white Blaine Sumner
Elementary suffice to say that Richard
was out of his comfort zone but he took
a page out of Jerry Lewis's book and
started imitating his clumsy childlike
Persona the other kids found it funny
his teacher found it funny too and even
began giving him 10 minutes every Friday
afternoon to perform his new routines by
becoming the class clown Richard Pryor
found acceptance from his peers for the
first time in his life and got his first
taste of success as a performer
Richard's amateur comedy career
continued into high school he briefly
joined the youth theater guild at the
Carver Community Center in Peoria where
he met future playwright and civil
rights activist Juliet Whittaker who
encouraged him to pursue his passion
inspired by her Richard start developing
his own characters his favorite oh was
the ram damage cell Ranger who was a
black superhero who was too poor to buy
his own stuff and instead had to wear
whatever he found at rummage sales like
women's tights and shoes that were too
big but you know what they say
everybody's a Critic one day the science
teacher Mr Fink was fed up with Richard
distracting all the other kids at the
back of the class think grabbed him by
the Scruff of the neck and prior took a
swing at him and was expelled
immediately now that he was a high
school dropout Richard needed to find
work for the next couple of years he
drifted in and out of employment in a
series of dead end jobs janitor shoe
shine boy delivery boy Factory hands
none of them lasted long in 1958 prior
did something he soon came to regret in
his Hasty pursuit of Adventure he
enlisted in the Army all of a sudden the
18 year old kid who had never left
Illinois found himself across the ocean
in Germany yet the environment was
woefully familiar Pryor's commanding
officers were all racist Southerners and
the military brass in Germany felt like
it might well have been smack dab in the
middle of Mississippi inevitably racial
tensions erupted into a fight during
which prayer stabbed a white soldier in
the back he was arrested but in a moment
of harmonious Serendipity the base
commander was just getting ready to
retire he didn't want to deal with all
the extra paperwork over some fight
between GIS so he just sent prior home
to Illinois back in Peoria Richard took
a few big steps in his life in 1960 he
met and married Patricia Price the first
of seven marriages for Prague with each
one only lasting a few years he also
decided to make a go of it as an
Entertainer he reached out to a few
friends who ran nightclubs and got some
experience in front of a live audience
once prayer felt that his material was
good enough he decided it was time to go
big or go home he packed up his bags and
headed for New York City success in the
Big Apple came surprisingly swiftly
prior was completely unknown in these
parts so he decided that he could be
anyone he wanted instead of the real
Richard who grew up in a dysfunctional
environment so the least he was a
clean-cut soft-spoken high school
graduate and former sports star he
modeled his Persona on another black
comedian who was making waves at the
time Bill Cosby unlike the real Cosby
that we know bent hate today early Cosby
portrayed himself as an affable guy who
appealed to all audiences by relying on
safe and clean Universal comedy with no
racial elements using the same approach
prior became a mainstead several comedy
clubs pretty fast within the year he
made his television debut on a variety
show called on Broadway tonight in the
years that followed prior scored
appearances on major TV shows like the
Ed Sullivan Show The Tonight showed the
craft Musical and the Merv Griffin show
in 1967 he even made his film debut with
a small role in The Comedy the busybody
but more and more prior felt that there
was a disconnect between the friendly
and lovable comic that saw people on
television and the real Richard Pryor
the one who was angry over all of the
crap that he had to endure in his life
the one who liked to get high and get
laid whenever possible the one who
wanted to Sucker Punch America in the
gut when it expected to be tickled in
the ribs in his own words prior felt
there was a world of junkies and Winos
pool Hustlers and prostitutes screaming
inside his head trying to be heard the
longer he kept them bottled up the
harder they tried to escape and
inevitably Escape they did turning
Richard Pryor into one of the most
profane but also profound voices in the
history of Comedy sponsor of today's
video is one of my absolute favorites if
you've ever wanted to start a website
but have been put off by the sort of
complicated coding then Squarespace is
perfect for you building an online
presence can be incredibly daunting but
no longer is an advanced coding degree
or small fortune required to get started
Squarespace helps you stand out with
beautiful website built using their easy
drag and drop method the platform also
provides you with powerful analytics and
insights into who visits your site and
how they interact with your content
squarespace's analytics tools include
page views traffic sources audience
geography and more figure out what is
drawing your audience in and capitalize
on that premium data that's provided to
you the Squarespace members area feature
also makes it easy for you to monetize
your content in a way that fits with
your brand unlock a new Revenue stream
for your business and sell exclusive
access to gated content for your most
dedicated customers and Squarespace
allows you to integrate email campaigns
into your website as well convert your
email subscribers into loyal customers
with their huge selection of email
templates and automation features test
out their platform and its features
before making any commitments you can go
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your website
go to squarespace.com biographics to
save 10 of your first purchase of a
website or a domain and now back to
today's video
it was September 1967 and Richard Pryor
was booked for a run at the Aladdin
Hotel in Las Vegas by this point he had
established himself firmly in the comedy
world and sold out crowds had become the
norm for him although they were all
coming to see a Persona of Richard proud
didn't actually exist in real life maybe
it was all the pent-up frustrations
maybe it was the drugs or the anxiety
but as soon as prayer stepped on stage
he saw Dean Martin at one of the front
tables staring at him so is everyone
else in the audience and they all
legally anticipated but the comedian to
say something prior described this
experience as an epiphany and after a
few long moments of Silence he blurted
out in front of the crowd what the [ __ ]
am I doing here then he turned around
and walked off stage muttering to
himself and later he received very angry
call from his manager who warned him
that it never work in Vegas again
afterward the facade that prior had
built for himself for the sake of his
career slowly started to come down for
the first time ever he was re-examining
all the experiences he had had in Peoria
but this time not as a kid who was too
young to understand what was really
happening but as a man who was ready to
present his life to the public raw
uncensored and uncut and people found it
funny the comedian recorded his first
Comedy album in 1968 simply titled
Richard Pryor and it was followed by 20
more over the course of his career five
of which one the Grammy for best comedy
album but this new Richard Pryor was
also a man who indulged in his vices
without a care in the world which in
this case meant drugs booze and women he
partied with the likes of Miles Davis
and Paul Mooney it wasn't uncommon for
him to spend all night in a club with
red fox battling each other for the
attention of a sexy waitress listening
to Jazz and snorting cocaine by the
Spoonful this Behavior took a toll on
Richard's personal life by 1970 his
second marriage had already fallen apart
the money that prior was not spending on
alimony payments he either smoked it or
shot it straight up his nose he also had
to deal with two family tragedies in
quick succession when his stepmother and
his father died less than a year apart
but professionally but I was
experiencing the greatest success of his
life his third album became a
breakthrough hit that sold well won a
Grammy and propelled prior and comedy
stardom his next two albums also won
Grammys giving Rara a rare three Peters
are one of only four people to win it
three years in a row he wrote for
multiple hit television shows during the
first half of the 70s and even won an
Emmy in 1974 as a co-writer for a Lily
Tomlin special prior appeared on the
first season of Saturday Night Live
becoming the first black person to host
it and unsurprisingly the episode also
happened to feature one of the most
controversial skits in the show's near
50-year history where a word association
game between prior and Chevy Chase
quickly turned into a tension-filled
contest of racial epithets briefly the
comedian always given his own variety
show in 1977 the Richard Pryor Show
which was canceled after only four
episodes due to his unflinching
unwillingness to tone down his material
his acting star was also on the rise as
prior appeared in over a dozen movies
during the decade worth mentioning here
is the Buddy comedy Silver Streak which
marked Richard Pryor's first on-screen
bearing with Gene Wilder as the duo went
on to make three more movies together
prior's first living hedonistic
lifestyle was not without consequences
the 70s saw the beginning and end of his
third marriage at one point Pryor was
even arrested and charged with assault
with a deadly weapon for shooting up his
wife's car during an argument she wasn't
in it at the time and the charges were
later dropped but the divorce came soon
after in 1977 brass suffered his first
heart attack due to all of the drugs and
alcohol but for the first time his party
habits also affected him professionally
in 1974 prior lost out on what would
have probably been the biggest movie
role of his career it was certainly the
biggest one of the decade he helped
co-ride Blazing Saddles with Mel Brooks
at satirical Western which is now
preserved in the Library of Congress and
has been ranked by the American filament
due to the sixth best comedy in American
Cinema Brooks wanted Richard Pryor for
the lead alongside Gene world but the
studio put the kibosh on the idea
considering prior to much of a wild card
due to his drug use this wouldn't be the
last role that pra would miss out on but
it became the biggest what if of his
professional career
foreign
[Music]
decade continued the same mixed bag of
highs and lows Richard Pryor with the
lows typically coming as a result of his
unchecked devices the Year 1980 is a
perfect example of this prior began the
decade by starring in the major hit stir
crazy once again alongside Gene Wilder
which was directed by Sydney Poitier and
became the first movie from a black
director to gross over 100 million
dollars made even more impressive by the
fact that it was R rated we'd say that
that counts as a pretty lofty High which
was immediately brought down when prior
almost killed himself by setting himself
on fire on June 10 1980 the comedian was
admitted to the hospital in critical
condition with severe burns over half
his body this was after he was spotted
running down the streets of Los Angeles
on fire for years the story was the
prior it set himself Ablaze from an
accidental explosion while freebasing
cocaine only later did he reveal that he
intentionally set himself on fire during
a drug-induced psychosis and that he
doused himself in liquor and flicked on
a lighter after that once more came the
high following weeks of excruciating
rehab in the hospital bra moved to
Hawaii for some peace and quiet he got
clean trading the drugs for fruit juice
Scenic Landscapes growing orchids and
learning to fly a plane even used his
Inferno Fiasco as material for his next
comedy show this was called live on the
Sunset Strip and it was another
grammy-winning effort that was
accompanied by prior's most successful
concert film but this new and improved
Richard Pryor was not around for long
Monty was back in La it only took him
until he found one of his secret stashes
before he started getting high again
even a few more close calls did nothing
to deter on March the 4th 1982 actor
John Belushi came around the comedy
store looking for prior to go up
partying but he couldn't find him so
instead he ended up alone at the Chateau
Marmon at night where he died of a
cocaine overdose the following morning
then a while later while filming the toy
at on-site Jackie Gleason in Louisiana
prior's heart started pounding so hard
that he had to be rushed to the hospital
speaking of the toy Perez acting credits
during the 1980s were nothing worth
writing home about he eventually
realized Hollywood's formulaic slot
usually performed better at the box
office than anything worthwhile so most
of his roles became nothing but
paychecks for him this culminate with
Superman 3 where prior was paid 4
million dollars to play an evil henchman
not only a record for a black actor at
the time but also reportedly more than
the lead actor Christopher Reeve was
paid prior had one attempt at cinematic
creativity with JoJo Dancy or life is
calling in 1986 representing prayer's
only directorial effort it was a
biographical comedy drama which he also
co-wrote and starred in but it was a
flop at the box office which only
reinforced Pryor's beliefs that he was
better off starring in generic and
Mindless crap
[Music]
1986 was a year that changed Richard
Pryor's life forever he noticed that he
was losing a lot of weight his eyesight
was getting worse sometimes he would
lose his balance and fall to the ground
for no apparent reason he feared that he
might have AIDS but he got tested and it
came back negative something was
definitely wrong though so he went to
the Mayo Clinic to get a bunch of tests
done and the result was devastating
Richard Pryor had multiple sclerosis
even though it was in its infancy he
knew that the disease was unpredictable
and the symptoms were only likely going
to get worse but just prior at Ms did
not mean that all of his other health
problems caused by Decades of decadence
and debauchery simply went away in 1990
he suffered a second heart attack
ironically after getting clean at the
Betty Ford Center then one day while he
was filming another U his last movie was
Gene Wilder prior woke up and his legs
simply wouldn't move his ability to walk
still came and went at this time but
that was the day the prior realized that
Ms took over for a man who used to party
who were the best of them prior now had
to resign himself to life in the slow
lane hopefully with no more surprises
but even tragedy afforded prior the
occasion for Liberty every now and then
one morning in 1992 the news reported
that Richard Pryor had died when in fact
he was sleeping in his bedroom this
prompted his panicked housekeeper to
enter the room and make a lot of noise a
first prayer offered no response but he
woke up screaming after the housekeeper
pinched his doe to check if he was still
alive the startled woman explained that
she thought he was dead because he was
lying on the bed with his eyes closed
not hardly moving to which Pryor replied
that's how I sleep how do you do it the
same year prior a new comedy material
and performed a concert of her the first
time in almost six years he couldn't
stand up anymore and he had to sit in an
easy chair for the duration of the show
but the night was a hit and bra hoped
that he could go on tour again however
just a few more gigs Zapped him of all
the strength that he had and he had to
cancel the rest of the tour realizing
that he had more heart than energy this
failure destroyed him emotionally and
from that moment on the comedian decided
that he had no choice but to step out of
the Limelight during the 90s Pryor only
made a handful of TV and movie
appearances a highlight was a guest spot
on the medical drama Chicago Hope where
he played a bit of patient with MS and
actually secured an Emmy nomination for
his final worthwhile performance as an
actor prize fourth wife Jennifer Lee
returned to him and acted as his
caretaker the two got married again in
2001 and she stood by his side until
December 10 2005 when Richard Pryor died
of a heart attack at the age of 65.
foreign